[Music]
[Music]
wow
luca that was hard to watch you uh
coming
[Music]
we do not go anywhere near the surface
got it
everything good is above the surface
walking air
the sky clouds the sun whoa
don't look at it just kidding definitely
look at it
have you ever gone to the human town
yeah
i'm kind of an expert
[Applause]
[Music]
someone got lucky today
hey leave them alone hop on go start the
club
for losers
my name is julia marcovaldo we underdogs
have to look out for each other
what's under the dogs
this is my dad what do you think he
kills with those
anything that swims
your life is so much cooler than mine
there's a million things you think you
can't do
all you need is a chance to try
fishy with youtube this is too
dangerous
i know your problem you got a bruno in
your head a bruno say
silencio bruno
[Music]
can you still hear him nope just you
good
now hang on
[Music]
what's wrong with you stupido you do it
now just say the thing
what's wrong with you stupidoh